hey you guys
it's the movie retrospective going back
to the 1970s for this one
um a movie that maybe if you were just
kind of watching it you weren't really
paying attention that you might think
was a hammer movie
but no it's not a hammer movie it's
actually from their sort of
rival studio amicus it's pretty good
movie and this is called
and now the screaming starts sometimes
with a exclamation point sometimes
without
it still delivers like a hammer film you
know
good looking european girls boobs poop
best
although it's not multiple boobs in this
one it's just one ladies yeah and one
and one woman's
one woman yeah she was and she was kind
of she was kind of big fine for her time
too
she was big fine for her time yeah the
dudes that were going to abuse her said
something
called her buxom yeah yes
it was a good flick it's a kind of like
um
it's almost kind of like like i said
like a british hammer horror film
take on kind of like the hand if you
said that michael
came with the hand it seems to be that
but there's more to it than that there's
curses and [ __ ]
ghosts and [ __ ] ghost rape yeah there's
all kinds of weird stuff and vengeance
and
everyone's like ghost rape now you've
got my attention
it's pretty good movie one of the things
i liked about this movie
versus say like a hammer film a hammer
film i think was a little more of a
grand production
a lot more a lot more sexual really when
you when you really get down to the yeah
all right um but what i liked about this
movie is that it was not dialogue driven
it was
it was a visual film it was very you
know visual it had dialogue in it but it
was mostly about
you know visuality yeah that's a word
visualization visual or something no it
was just you know it
it was showing not telling you know what
i'm talking about yeah i mean they had
to have more dialogue toward the end as
they were like explaining the mystery
and stuff right
um yeah so this came out in 1973.
uh its main title that it's usually
known by is and now the screaming starts
but it's also known as fen griffin or
bride of fen griffin um i guess the
novel that it was based on was called
fen griffin it was by
um david case so that title makes more
sense actually
it yeah it does um there is a lot of
screaming in this movie i will say but
yeah but that's awful vague that sounds
like something the italians would call
their movie
yeah it really does not like that now
like i said this is
this is an interesting movie because as
i said this is not hammer um
it's actually amicus and if you know
anything about british horror amicus
what they usually did was one they were
primarily known for doing
anthology or quote-unquote portmanteau
movies like horror anthologies
and almost all of their movies were uh
had contemporary settings whereas uh
hammer
was more known for their gothic uh stuff
so this is a very unusual amicus film in
the sense that it is one
you know full-length film rather than an
anthology and it's also set in the
gothic time period so you can kind of
see
that amicus i think at this point like
night early 1970s i think even hammer
was starting to have like diminishing
returns on a lot of their uh
movies because their movies were kind of
going out of fashion and you could see
that like the hammer ones in the early
1970s they even tried to do
more like gothic stuff but in a more
contemporary setting like you know
dracula 80 1970 or so you know where the
monsters were coming to the
groovy modern era yeah what was that
modern
um so it's it was very strange of amicus
to kind of want to go
back to i believe this is set in the
1700s
well no when yeah both 17 and 1800s
yeah remember because it takes place
across a couple generations
yeah like two or three i think it's like
a 50-year like time span
so it ended up in the 1800s according to
what they were wearing
yeah i guess so yeah yeah because when i
was watching it i couldn't figure out
what time period it was because i'm like
it's
it's a time period you don't often see
like the costuming is was a little
strange
i believe it ends in the early 1800s
yeah because i think that
initially i think it was set and
supposed to be set 1795 maybe yeah
something like that but uh yeah so the
thing about amicus and hammer i don't
like i said i don't i hate to call them
rivals necessarily because they
borrowed a lot of the same uh directors
and same actors and stuff peter cushing
is in this and it was directed by
roy ward baker who did a bunch of hammer
movies he did equator mass in the pit he
did
um and then he did a bunch of amicus
once too he did asylum he did vault of
horror
he did all that kind of stuff so they
you know borrowed back and forth a lot
so the interesting thing about this too
is that when i first saw it like when i
saw the house like fen griffin manor or
whatever the [ __ ] it's called in the
movie
i was like god damn there's that [ __ ]
house again because that's in like so
many movies
that is an actually well i looked it up
and it's like a pretty famous house in
the uk it's called oakley court
it's a hotel now but i guess when hammer
first started out in 1949 that was like
their headquarters for a year or two and
they did like some live productions
there they shot a bunch of their movies
there
also i you know where i recognized it
from rocky horror picture show
yeah that was like dr frankenfurter's
castle and rocky horror picture show
all right so and like i said this has a
lot of the same actors
it says you know stephanie beecham's in
it patrick mcgee is in it
um you know so so there's a lot of um
you know amicus players and hammer
players as well like in this movie so
all right so let's talk a little bit
about
the story of this because this one's
kind of a weird one
um so this woman
who is uh her name's catherine and she's
just married
this you know upper-class twit type dude
charles feng griffin
and they're going back to his uh
palatial estate or whatever
and pretty much from the jump it does
seem like
it's really funny because like literally
like two minutes after the movie starts
i was like boobs tom boom
i missed it that's the thing man
the british studios were it's obvious to
me that they knew exactly why
people were coming to see these movies
they had to get asses in the seats
yeah all right they were horror movies
they had good looking people both male
and female in the damn movies in these
badass costumes the women were of course
they were [ __ ] sexy it was boob fest
all right and um there were sexual
undertones and
overtones i mean i would think that the
hammer films are a little more intense
to this this is a good movie but the
camera ones were a little more intense
it was more women
all of them real good looking more boobs
uh
more sex i mean they're getting down
with carmilla they're lesbian vampires
and [ __ ] like that it's just like yeah i
mean they weren't they weren't
they weren't softcore porn but they were
they were sexual
they were a little racy yeah today yeah
they stayed you know it was 60s and 70s
yeah they could get away with all kinds
of stuff
sexual revolution stuff and so
people went and saw they were good i
feel like hammers were
slightly gorier as well yeah the amicus
ones tended to be a little less gory
yeah women were gonna see it because
there's an element of romance
to them they were [ __ ] stylish looking
you know stylish sets and stuff they
were they they were they were sexy
guys were seeing them because the horror
the blood [ __ ] boobs and [ __ ] you
know i mean they were good stories they
were just they were just good stories
yeah i couldn't see why they went out of
fashion but they were good stories they
kind of can come back around
fashion they're gothic yeah and i feel
like you know
probably 10 years ago or something like
that they had a little bit of a gothic
mini resurgence she had like you know
there was a remake of the woman in black
they did crimson peak they did all that
kind of stuff so you know it's
it's kind of you know and look at
[ __ ] twilight and [ __ ] like that
that's kind of like
a big story too so you know so far you
know i haven't seen them all but so far
i like the carmilla one the best
yeah that's probably my favorite i don't
know it's hard to pick
i haven't seen all of them but i have
seen a lot of the hammer and amicus
movies
yeah carmilla was pretty sexy
[Laughter]
who doesn't love lesbian vampires come
on yeah and it had it was nothing but
just good-looking women
and men trying to stop this lesbianism
and everyone watching is like no don't
you don't stop
why are you trying to stop yeah
right you're [ __ ] fine i know so all
right so catherine uh marries this dude
charles fen griffin and they go to his
you know families estate or whatever
and uh actually they get married there
don't they because they show like
briefly at the beginning
now pretty much immediately uh she's
kind of wandering through the portrait
gallery and he's like and this is my
great grandfather this person and this
is my group and she's like oh
fascinating you know what i mean
pretending she's interested
so you know what i mean so then she sees
this one painting in particular
of this dude he doesn't look super
sinister or anything in particular but
she just really really does not like
this portrait at all and she's kind of
like
mesmerized by it and then all of a
sudden jump scare this big [ __ ]
bloody hand to like cop pops out of the
uh
pops out of the painting and i was like
oh yeah nice one that's i wasn't
expecting that okay
now um that particular night
i guess that she's waiting in her room
to for the wedding night lovin or
whatever
and the husband is going to his quarters
to do whatever it is he has to do
like before this all can be consummated
or whatever
and so while she's in there she gets all
her little nighty on and fixes her hair
and everything and she like
gets in the bed and then all of a sudden
um because they've showed like prior to
this there's like a little
uh severed hand kind of like walking
around you know
like a thing it looks like adam's family
it's actually not bad for like 1973
looks good yeah i mean you can tell that
it's you know a mechanical
hand but it still looks i mean the
outside looks pretty good it's like a
little severed hand going
yeah and the font and everything i like
the thought for the [ __ ] credits they
had that 70s it's the same font from
excalibur
and and it does kind of feel like it's
from that same era of the movie
excalibur
even though excalibur didn't come well
excalibur didn't come out till 1981
no i thought yeah i thought it was late
70s i thought it was more like 78.7 i'm
pretty sure it was 81.
it still it still looked about the well
the 81 was still
70. it was still fair yeah the font that
they used for this movie i told them i
was like that is the entire decade in
the 1970s in one particular font i feel
like they use that for everything
yeah that was their mystical celtic font
it was yeah so it's like everybody uses
that so every time i [ __ ] say that
it's a mystical [ __ ] and it really
happened it is right yeah so you've seen
this little like kind of
severed hand like scooting around like i
said like thing from the adams family
so she's in the bedroom and all of a
sudden
um the severed hand it looks like the
severed hand like smells like is over
her mouth right
and then there's like a a stump like an
arm stump yeah that's like holding her
down
and then it's implied that she's uh
raped by a ghost yeah and then what's
funny is that every time one of these
paranormal events happens she starts
screaming and
when the dudes show up and there's
nothing there and they're like oh she's
obviously crazy
woman yes woman and women don't know
what they're seeing
that's it they can't do that again yeah
i really
i felt for this poor woman because the
thing about catherine in this movie so
it's like every time
she knows pretty much immediately
because like i said you know the night
she gets to the house and sees the
weirdest painting with the hand popping
out
and then she gets raped by a ghost for
[ __ ] sake like the first night
and then her husband's like what are you
screaming about and she was just like
okay so it's gone now whatever women
don't know reality all right and then
and then
like too like when her even though um
you know she just got raped by a ghost
then her husband's still expecting like
oh it's wedding night sex she's like
okay i gotta go through with this now
because even though i just got raped by
a ghost but he doesn't believe her right
yeah so it's like then while they're
getting down then she looks out the
window and sees a dude out there with no
eyes yeah ghost with no eyes yeah he's
like those big bloody sockets and [ __ ]
like that you know she's like well i'm
that put me right yeah
you know women you know they just they
just see things which is i've seen
things
i just constantly see [ __ ] all i'm
seeing [ __ ] right now yeah right
the man kind of come in shit's like
[ __ ] flying around come in and
straighten that [ __ ] out you're just
seeing things
why you screaming
this is kind of like that trope writ
lard but the thing about it it's like
the reason it doesn't
bother me that much is because the woman
always turns out to be right there
really is supernatural [ __ ] going on
it's just the men are too dumb to like
see it i guess
what's funny is that i think that trope
kind of played into the stereotype in
the paranormal scene that women are more
sensitive than men yeah that's exactly
right
well you're getting that from the movies
in the movies the [ __ ] it's it's
it it's written that way you know what i
mean for to suspense that
to make the woman like she's privy to
some secret knowledge the ghosts are
picking on her
yeah all right she's not crazy these men
are crazy that's what that's
that's what that's what the story means
these men can't see the truth
yeah that's really what it is i mean
pretty much yeah like i said you it
really does go back to that women are
more mystical and
yeah in tune with like forces that do
yeah generally [ __ ] around about
women don't know what they see because
that's what the man is saying in the
face but you know that
that's that's playing into a kind of a
feminist stereotype
that the men are saying the women are
crazy that's not what the story you're
you're you're you're misinterpreting
what the story meant
the story means that the men can't see
what's really going on the woman does
yeah that's what it really means well
yeah because like i said they're always
the women always are yeah they'll end up
being right right yeah the thing that is
okay so the really frustrating thing
about this
for the character and like i said i
really kind of felt the [ __ ] because she
sees all this crazy [ __ ] happening
obviously um you know the the dude is
not seeing any of it her husband's not
seeing any of it
so she maybe starts to think well maybe
i'm not i don't know but then
she's actually got her [ __ ] pretty much
together because she's like okay
something weird is going on in this
house
my husband knows some weird [ __ ] the
servants know this weird [ __ ]
and no one's telling me so she gets like
really frustrated about it
now another thing that happens too is
that after the whole ghost rape thing
and seeing the creepy dude outside the
window with no eyes
she is like farting around on the
property you know
and she finds this little cottage and
she goes in there and the dude that
lives in there whose name is silas he's
a woodsman
and he has this big red birthmark on the
side of his face
just like the guy that she saw outside
of the window so i think that seeing
that guy
and that he's really alive and [ __ ] um
that was what cemented
hey look i'm seeing something there's
something weird going on here and nobody
is telling me what it is
yeah what's the name of that actress do
you uh do you remember stephanie beecham
she was in a bunch of hammer films as
well yeah and i'll tell you what she
does a great job
uh you know everybody in these british
movies can act
they're they're yeah you just you have
to it's not like hollywood
where if you have enough blow you can be
in the movie it's not like
just bring the blow and you can yeah
bring the blow or blow and you can be in
the movie that's
that that's kind of how hollywood does
it uh no in
in in england you had to be from the
theater and another thing is and it's
part of this
also a thing about good british movies
of this era
and a lot of movies of this era some of
the american ones were like this too
if you were going to be a leading lady
you had to be smoking hot i mean they
were
unabashed about it you know i mean that
yeah
you're in this movie because you can act
and you look like a model
yeah and also titties yeah yeah so
because people pay to see good looking
people back then i think they still do
um yeah yeah so they knew what they were
doing and she's smoking hot
she's and she and she fits the character
yeah like i said she was in a [ __ ] on a
movie
probably not just hammer but she was in
september and i think she was another
amicus and you know they were fair you
know they [ __ ] brought in eye candy
for the women too you know what i mean
they get put macho type dudes and then
you know
they understand how kinky certain women
are because [ __ ] they're bringing in
[ __ ] peter cushing and you know he's
a sex symbol
and his skinny [ __ ] with his [ __ ]
cheek bones
uh women had a thing for that old dude
he was he looked good
well the thing about this one's spooky
looking he is spooky looking yeah and i
dig that see
yeah well the thing about it is that in
this particular movie and this is kind
of sad i don't mean to bring everybody
down but
in this particular movie he was like
maybe a little bit thinner than usual
because he had only his wife and only
died like a year or something before
and he was still because i was watching
an interview with somebody that worked
on the movie
and they said once his wife died um you
know he was still in movies and he still
gave his all and everything
but they said he was just really just
waiting to die to join her waiting
around to die
that's basically what he said um he'd
lost a lot of weight and he was kind of
it's insane how skinny that dude was
very skinny i mean i'm looking at that
dude i'm like man
does he have back teeth it almost looks
like he does it
yeah because i was looking at you i'm
like damn they're only he's got teeth in
the front does he have
back and his cheekbones are just i mean
they're like raisins
it's almost kind of like you'd have to
damn pay for cosmetic surgery to get
cheekbones that much
now i know that his arms at the bicep
were probably about the diameter of my
wrists i mean he was a
skinny dude but that was just some bad
ass cheekbones on that man
i know you probably had the world's best
channel and
he's a legend in america just from that
one roll out of the star wars and
playing [ __ ]
general tarkin yeah [ __ ] and it just
that dude
perfect for that role yeah he's just
you know how do you not like i said how
do you not love peter cushing and
christopher lee man that's like you know
what i mean they're [ __ ] everybody
loves them yeah
but yeah so so he doesn't turn up until
later but yeah yeah
he shows up as the wise dude he's always
the dude's gotta sort [ __ ] out he's
intelligent
i was like oh you could tell i mean
that's what i said when the carriage got
there like about a third of the way or
two thirds of the way for through maybe
i said peter cushing arrives just store
it everything's gonna store it
he'll figure it out yeah because you
don't know what the hell's going on
well yeah it's like that's the thing and
i think that a lot of people
um i watched some other reviews of
there's not a [ __ ] ton this is actually
on shutter at the moment because shutter
just added a bunch of
amicus movies i also did a review of um
asylum the the anthology movie but that
won't be out for a few more weeks
but um yeah so so it's on shutter in the
u.s if you want to watch it
but i think that some people complained
oh it's a little slow or it was a little
i didn't really find it i mean i could
see how somebody might think that
but i didn't really find it all that i
really liked the atmosphere of it i
really liked the mystery
because the whole time you're seeing she
keeps seeing this weird [ __ ]
like this you know this [ __ ] hand
crawling around
you know this [ __ ] eyeless dude
popping up
and then another like other weird [ __ ]
starts to happen like i said because
she's pretty
sure that her husband and the servants
at the house like know about what's
going on and are just like
[ __ ] with her and like telling you
it's like oh you don't see anything blah
blah so she's getting really frustrated
so you have that whole aspect
and then what starts to happen is that
some of her servants
start feeling bad for her and are like
okay well i'm gonna tell her what's
going on like i think the first person
that feels bad for her
she goes to see um the family solicitor
and he's kind of like okay well i'm not
really supposed to tell you i'm kind of
you know i'm kind of afraid to but uh
your husband said not to
but i'll come by tonight and we'll all
talk about it together and then he
coincidentally gets uh like axe murdered
on the way to the house that night
and then subsequently every time
someone's gonna tell her what the [ __ ]
is going on like one of her servants is
gonna tell her and then
she gets like [ __ ] strangled by a
ghostly severed hand
one of the other servants is going to
tell her and she you know but
it always like looks like an accident
like oh she just fell down the stairs or
she just had a heart attack or whatever
so at this point she's just like [ __ ]
losing it because she's like
i feel like everybody knows what's going
on three people that are were gonna tell
me what was going on have died
um you know but with plausible
deniability so the husband's just like
oh the first guy just got murdered by
highwaymen and the other two were just
accidents and
natural causes and all this other kind
of [ __ ] but you know the whole time that
the husband [ __ ] knows what's going
on and he's not coughing it up yeah he
knows something about some of the
servants some of the servants know
yeah but you know what's funny is that
you said that some people say that it's
kind of slow
the first part of it the reason why
they're saying that is because
there's not a lot of dialogue yeah it's
showing you stuff that's happening
and there's not a lot of explanation so
it seems like it takes a long time
but hammer did that too yeah the
difference was is that
hammer padded that that would have
padded that time out
with a lot more boobs yeah yeah had that
[ __ ]
and made sure they had all the servant
girls with the bustiers and the [ __ ]
popping up
[ __ ] the woman would have had a
couple more hot friends to always
comment
and they had to sit at the tops of the
booth popping up out of there muffin top
yeah yeah and then it would have been
like leaning over the bed
to ask her the question you know so that
would have padded that out
and that's what's missing from this
movie that's why they're saying it's a
little bit slow
they would get hammer would have [ __ ]
put a lot more eye candy in that first
one third you know first half of the
movie would have been a lot more of that
and you wouldn't have noticed it yeah
it would have been the same [ __ ] would
have happened just as some boobs had
been watching it happen
and reacting to it happen you know what
that's not
sorry yeah the boobs react to it just
let's be honest some of those girls in
those hammer movies were there because
of their boobs
well yeah and they were just okay we
need you to stand here in the corner
when this [ __ ] happens
scream and we'll look and then we'll
zoom in on your cleavage okay then we'll
go in and then
that they were doing that let's see how
they didn't zoom in let's see how the
boobs feel about this yeah
they were doing that it was boob
reaction
oh my god that should be our new chip
how do you play boob reaction yeah it's
a very situation that was hammer's game
yeah hammer knew what it was doing you
know
but yeah okay this is going to happen
it's going to come through when we need
a servant girl over here to scream
who's got the biggest boobs yeah okay
yeah hike him up a little bit higher
okay
darling standing in the corner right
here we can get action you know i mean
and then
so that way it was just a constant
stream that kind of [ __ ] happened it
yeah in a hammer punch yeah yes it was
yeah all right so
like i said now every time somebody's
trying to tell this poor woman what the
[ __ ] is really going on
um you know that that person
mysteriously dies
uh also you know that silas the woodman
woodsman the guy that lives out in the
woods with the weird birthmark
he's up to some creepy [ __ ] too because
at one point the husband uh charles like
rides out there is like hey i
just want you off this land and he's
like no i don't want to leave
even though the guy's like um hey i'll
give you all this money you can move to
london you can do whatever you want i'll
give you as much money as you want
if you leave because you're you know
making my wife upset
and he's like nah so you know that there
has to be some kind of
because he makes these like really weird
statements about
um you know the land and about his uh
father and grandfather and [ __ ] like
that so at one stage
uh if you will remember catherine has
been raped by a ghost right now she also
had sex with her husband so you know it
could go either way
but uh so they call the doc this doctor
who's played by patrick mcgee
and uh his name's dr whittle and he
shows up and he's like oh guess what
catherine you're pregnant and she's like
oh [ __ ] me and the
you know so they're like okay well she's
not happy about this so then dr whittle
goes and talks to
charles and dr whittle knows what the
[ __ ] is going on too but no one is gonna
tell
us and no one is gonna tell him because
they're just like well don't don't you
think you should tell her now that she's
pregnant you know this
might go badly or whatever now the thing
about it too
is that finally you know she's just like
[ __ ]
losing her mind because she just knows
something's going on and no one's
telling her so at that stage charles
calls in peter cushing to like i said
sort everything out now he plays like a
psychiatrist i guess he's supposed to be
a psychiatrist
named named dr pope and he shows up
with his fabulous fabulous outfits holy
crap he's got some great [ __ ] outfits
in his [ __ ] cheek and his cheekbones
yeah his cheekbones will fix everything
cheekbones increase your iq by 40 points
[Laughter]
make you a lot smarter yeah yeah so dr
pope
uh he comes there and he tries to sort
out like what is going on with her and
she tells him about all the dreams she's
had and how she thinks everybody knows
some information that they're not
telling her
and it's upsetting so he tends to think
he's like a man of science and
everything so he doesn't think there's
anything supernatural going on he just
he doesn't think she's crazy but he just
thinks oh maybe because she's pregnant
or maybe it's all new maybe the stress
is just too much for her whatever
now he actually goes to talk to dr
whittle the other doctor
and dr whittle is about to tell dr pope
about the [ __ ] that's going on
and then dr whittle drops dead so at
this point dr pope's like
huh this is really weird so finally he
goes to charles the husband is like look
[ __ ] tell me what the [ __ ] is
going on because everybody's just like
dropping dead and this is not
cool and charles is just kind of like
well it's just a legend i didn't think
it was true and he seems like [ __ ] tell
me what the [ __ ] legend is
so what the legend was that silas the
dude that lives out in the woods
it was his dad right okay yeah
so his dad also who looked who's played
by the same actor and he had like the
same
uh you know the same birthmark and all
that other kind of stuff it's like a red
diamond
yeah it's kind of like a like what do
they call that a port wine stain or
something like that i think they call it
yeah it's like just this red
shade yeah it's like on the half of his
face and uh so silas's father whose name
was also silas silas senior we'll call
him
he uh lived in this cottage he was a
woodsman too
and he worked for charles's grandfather
who was a real piece of [ __ ] um so the
grandfather
he i love the way they put this he made
the castle
uh a site of debauchery is that what
they said yeah it was some pretty mild
debauchery gotta say
at least at first he said it was they
said they filled it with the scum of the
earth and then when they showed them it
was just like
oh regular people poor people
oh it's the peasants yeah they were
playing drinking games yeah they were
just like drinking
and freaking having a good time yeah
yeah they weren't like sacrificing
babies or nothing like that it was just
it was pretty mild like partying yeah
but uh
but it actually gets worse from that
that that wasn't the whole well that was
a subset of people that went out to go
do the crime
that's true that wasn't it wasn't the
general population in there
yeah they had women in there and you
know the women wouldn't have stood for
that i don't think well i would hope not
yeah but back then maybe
maybe you would have because you just
because they'd have [ __ ] slapped your
ass around too
but yeah so i don't know i i i [ __ ]
read some contemporary stuff that
happened during those witch trials and
those women's were boisterous they would
speak up
but hey don't do that [ __ ] you know what
i mean but some of them did yeah you
know
so some of them did they weren't they
weren't all shrinking violets
no they had balls back then some girls
yeah oh i know they did
yeah yeah so uh so the thing about it is
that
the grandfather it's like after he's
gotten sick of this kind of just like
boring debauchery
so he takes like him and some of his
like little posse or whatever and
they're like hey
silas senior the woodsman he just got
married today
so let's go [ __ ] with him a little bit
so then they go out to the woodsman's
cottage
and basically before silas senior has
even
got in the new wife he's been giving her
a bath
they're doing a whole thing polishing up
his brand new woman
polishing up the brand new woman yeah
well you know and she's cute she's cute
yeah her name is sarah right yeah yeah
she's really cute kind of like a
kind of like a short stocky barbie
benton
yeah she did kind of look like yeah she
kind of looked like now i want to see
shortstop but just barbie ben was tall
yeah she wasn't i mean i didn't find her
she's not like no five
five she's five five four yeah she was
of
that you know she was supposed to be a
farm girl so she you know you know she
was supposed to be kind of
struck strong yeah stocky little star
shapely yeah she yeah she's just
starting yeah what they would what would
they call that they would call
never mind porn would have called it a
pog
[Laughter]
he knows he knows all the terminology he
knows all the poor life
yeah so this is florida guy
so uh charles fenn griffin's grandpa
and his little gang of miscreants
bust into this cottage uh before silas
has even had a chance to like you know
take his wife for a test drive or
whatever
and they're just yeah no that was the
maiden voyage that's true it wasn't even
yeah he already bought it yeah it was
the main voyage
yeah so before he hadn't even got to do
that yet and then
um uh ben griffin grandpa he decides
he's going to do that uh divine right of
kings they're not
yeah he's gonna go prima knock right
yeah that's what i was just getting
knocked him
that was back in the day where your lord
said uh uh
i'm getting it first yeah and the reason
why they did that back then is that they
always wanted the damn
lineage of the child to be questioned
yeah that way
you wouldn't revolt against your
landlord if that possibly could have
been your father yeah
so is to keep all that revolts into
check and you can get you some free
stuff
virgin yeah you know
that [ __ ] when it actually was going
back to the end of scotland
yeah they were doing that the british
were doing that but yeah so basically
the grandpa
rapes her yeah and then uh she
actually you know after she because
she's like freaking out screaming
obviously and then like after that
shit's over she's tries to attack him
with an axe i was like man go girl
yeah he rapes her and he's a dick about
it yeah
just like just to like put a little
cherry on top of the [ __ ]
too yeah yeah he tries to pull this
[ __ ] divine right and
and and and her her new husband but
mostly i'm finn what now
silas suicidal senior yes he's like ah
those days are over
since we you know we don't do that
anymore that's not the law and he's
basically saying i'm telling you what
the law is yeah he's like what the [ __ ]
he's
a gang of dudes you know what i mean
they they beat his
they force you know they force it to
happen you know they beat his ass up and
[ __ ] you know what i mean and then they
dragged him outside and cut his hand out
cut his hand off for [ __ ] talking and
she severed him
yeah yeah it was it was rude it was very
rude
uh yeah it was a tad bro yeah um but
yeah so they so they take him out and
cut his hand off like because he tried
to
actually he got he uh connected with the
axe i think but he just got him in the
shoulder or whatever
so then uh yeah so grandpa got a little
pissed off
and he said okay well i'm going to chop
that hand off so he chops the hand off
and uh at that point silas senior
basically
curses the fen griffin family and is
saying that
um the first virgin what is it i can't
remember the exact curse but it's
something like the first virgin bride
that comes to fen griffin
like uh they're gonna be uh violated
like my sarah was and you know it's so
so the lineage it's basically like ghost
rape he's basically saying like the
curse is going to
now when silas was gonna get his head
cut off like in
his his [ __ ] lord said [ __ ] gave
him the option you can beg for mercy
and he was like and he's like spits on
him [ __ ] you i was like
damn we shot his hands off so that so
they're letting you know that you know
he
had do or die willpower you know what i
mean he had quite you know
his honor content his honor content was
high
yeah he wasn't going to beg for mercy
even if it cost him his hand
and he didn't even yell when they cut
his hand and then he just put that dude
with his damn book hardcore
i'm so mad yeah well you know you had
all this rightfully so
we had all this psychic willpower which
could summon a curse that's what that
that's what they were talking about
there yeah
so basically because uh katherine back
in the present day
uh is you know suspected that something
weird was going on which is why
when she found out she was pregnant she
was really bummed because she was like i
don't want this baby she even tried to
like stab herself in the stomach at some
point
but the severed hand prevented the knife
from going all the way through like a
spiritual hand
yeah because it was well the curse said
that it's like no one could prevent it
you know what i mean that's why every
time somebody tried to tell her what was
going on they would die
they like they would get killed so
finally at the end like dr pope says
he's gonna stay until the baby is born
and uh so he does and she's like really
because we're like the first thing we
thought were like that she's going to
give birth to a severed hand i'm like
wow yeah
that's like that'd be really [ __ ] up
yeah if that happened
i was like i kind of like that idea i
was gonna be a little baby
a little baby yeah that would have been
a little that would have been a little
weird
um but yeah so she does actually end up
having a baby now they don't
like show it to you right away you can
kind of guess like what
what probably is going to happen with it
but she has the baby
and you know that here you hear the baby
crying and then the
the husband comes in and looks into the
cradle at which point i was like what
have you done to his
eyes you know what i mean because it was
kind of that kind of moment and um so he
looks in there and he's like oh [ __ ] no
and he like runs out of there
and then uh you know so finally peter
cushing comes and gives her the baby
yeah and she looks at it and i was like
it's gonna have a birthmark
like silas's birthmark yeah and it did
and
so it has this big birthmark and not
only that but it has like a little teeny
stump it doesn't have a hand i was like
oh i didn't expect him to go there
you missed a cool part of the story
though when the dude saw the baby and
[ __ ] he freaks out he runs down to the
cemetery i was gonna say that
cracks open the damn his grandfather's
grave because he was the one that was
responsible
and you see the body does this the
skeleton yeah
well it was the skeleton yeah jerky on
it you know the main [ __ ] and it's
all white and rotted he pulled it out
[ __ ] [ __ ]
it was so great breaking the [ __ ] up
[ __ ]
this is how much i hate my grandfather
i'm gonna like take his [ __ ] corpses
and fling it off
cushing was trying to stop it from
knocking it off
don't do it don't do it you know what i
mean and then he didn't happen he's like
and then he was like that that's some
sacrilegious [ __ ] right there
but i get you right he had the buckle on
his black helmet a black helmet black
black hat everything looked
damn in his pilgrim outfit with the
[ __ ] it wasn't it was cool yeah he
did look very cool
like i said he had some [ __ ] badass
outfit but i also yeah i was gonna uh
a point that because that was probably
my favorite moment of the whole movie
when
charles goes to his grandfather's crypt
or his tomb
rather and breaks it open with a [ __ ]
axe or whatever
and then pulls that body
like you ruined everything yeah because
now i have like a weird-ass baby that's
like
fathered by a ghost apparently i mean
because he's got yeah so the baby has
the
has the birthmark and doesn't have a
little hand i also liked to when uh
when peter cushing hands her the baby
and she just like looks at it and like
kind of hands it back and talks like
i don't want that yeah yeah yeah i don't
want that
that's what it sounded like that's it
here you take it but uh yeah so this is
uh
i actually really enjoyed this movie you
liked it too right yeah
yeah yeah it was kind of like a um
it was it delivered it was visual um
the sets costume was good acting is
really good um
the cast is good um real good actually
um
the story was like something that you'd
hear from you know
english irish scottish folklore you know
something like that
you know um it sounds like it feels kind
of like it's something legendary
was it is this a retelling of uh it's
just it's based on a novel but the novel
is from like 1970 right okay so it's
like a recent novel but it's a gothic
novel yeah it was set in the
1790s it feels like it's something more
like from you know the seventeen
hundreds or the eighteen hundreds you
know something yeah it's all the curses
and yeah
you know uh curses of the father's like
into the next generation
my only uh complaint about it is that
it's good as it is but it would have
competed a lot better i think against a
hammer film which is what it was trying
to do
if it had more boobs yeah it needed it
didn't eat them
because there was really only i mean
there's one main woman in it and she had
like a couple of servants and then
in the flashback you know silas seniors
they showed her for a few minutes but
it's obvious what it is they're trying
to do they're
trying to compete with hammer
um you've got a match hammer
in the in the the uh what do you call it
the sex appeal
error yeah [ __ ] quota quotient that
it that that hammer had
and it doesn't quite have that sex
appeal that hammer had
yeah it's more straight up more just
straight up and regular
maybe they were trying maybe what it was
is they were like yeah we want to
compete
with hammer but we don't really want we
don't really agree with that skin flick
kind of approach that they're adding
into there you know we're it's just
going to be good quality and stories and
yeah then maybe they want to be more
more more yeah it might be that we're
going to do a little more conservative
which now that's not what i would have
done in the 70s hell no
yeah well if anything i'd have been more
outrageous than hammer but i'm american
yeah and you know a big difference
between the mentality of a modern
american and
a british studio of that era yeah maybe
they thought the market would be
better responsive if it was a little
more conservative well maybe because
like i said
because i think that hammer had started
to go downhill at that point even though
they were doing more and more lurid
maybe they thought they were getting
maybe they saw it go more lured and they
thought there was diminishing response
that's what i would take it back take it
back to the more classic time
like i said amicus this wasn't usually
the type of movie they did i don't think
i don't think they did any other
full-length gothic movies they did a
movie back in 1966 i think called the
skull
and that had a little bit of a gothic
thing just like in the prologue part but
i think the rest of it was
kind of set in contemporary times almost
all of their movies were set in
contemporary times and almost all of
their movies were anthologies
so if you really like a lot of amicus um
anthology movies i think severin just
put a bunch of them out like the
that releasing company um and this is
kind of on one
i think they did like a big pack that
was like the amicus like
big set or whatever and um but it's so
if you like those and you want to see
kind of their take on a different genre
it's kind of amicus doing hammer you
know what i mean uh
you know this is actually a pretty good
one and uh honestly yeah i really really
liked it i liked the whole mystery
aspect i didn't really figure out what
was going on exactly
kind of kept me interested you know and
it was
it's a lot of good acting in it that the
cast seemed like smaller a bit than a
hammer film
more contained it needed two or three
more attractive women in the cast
you didn't have to do all the [ __ ]
things like the boob thing but there
should have been more attractive women
in the cast i think it would have been
better
yeah it did like i said it did seem like
a more contained story in the sense that
there were fewer characters
fewer locations that kind of stuff
because you could tell amicus didn't
have quite as much
money and power as maybe hammerhead yeah
because i think amicus tried to do stuff
like on the on lower end that's why they
didn't do a lot of period pieces because
they're generally more expensive to do
but yeah this like i said if you're in
the us and maybe in the uk i'm not
really sure but they uh
shutter just added a whole bunch of
amicus movies not too long ago
and this is on there as well along with
uh asylums on there
beast must die is on there there's a
bunch of different ones if you want to
check them out but yeah this is uh
totally a good one so if you're into 70s
british horror then
by all means check it out and we'll see
on the next one
bye